in deutschland herzlich willkommen zu
unserem corona kompakt wie immer mit dem
neuesten entwicklungen im überblick
unter anderem gibt es einen selbsttest
außerdem gucken wir nach würzburg dort
gibt es mittlerweile zehn corona
todesfälle in einem seniorenheim und im
anschluss daran beantwortet dr felix
zimmermann rechtliche fragen rund um
corona nichts geht mehr auf dem weg von
marokko zurück nach europa hunderte
wohnmobile auch mit deutschen urlaubern
stehen vor der spanischen exklave ciotat
im stau wegen des corona virus ist die
grenze geschlossen
und so bleibt den camper nichts anderes
übrig als zu warten bis sie endlich das
spanische gebiet auf afrikanischem boden
erreichen können um so die fähre zurück
zum europäischen festland zu nehmen
marokkanisches militär versorgt die
menschen mit dem nötigsten wann es hier
weitergeht weiß niemand
unsicherheit immer noch auch in
deutschland vor allem was die
lebensmittelversorgung an werden
verschiedene sachen aber das ist
kleinkram was man nicht unbedingt
braucht fühle ich mich gut versorgt ja
ja aber es ist trotzdem wenn die regale
noch leer sind ist man doch ein bisschen
panik versorger meine schwiegereltern 82
85 sind da also frisches gemüse wurst
butter wie wilhelmshaven kümmern sich
sogar mehr als 40 marinesoldaten um
einkäufe für kranke und alte menschen
wir möchten verhindern dass diese
risikogruppe sich einem unnötigen risiko
aussetzt beispielsweise indem sie nach
draußen geht um einkäufe zu machen das
machen wir jetzt stadt wilhelmshaven ist
traditionell eng mit der deutschen
marine verbunden eine
nachbarschaftshilfe wie diese liegt also
nahe
man betont dass es sich dabei nicht um
einen bundeswehreinsatz handelt als
marin will im schulterschluss mit der
stadt wilhelmshaven möchte ein bisschen
das leben was man auch von einer guten
ehe sagt dass man eben in guten zeiten
zusammen hält vor allem aber auch in
schlechten zeiten
und dabei steht die korona virus
epidemie erst am anfang also keine
entwarnung auch nicht für die jungen und
gesunden
ich betone dass auch immer wieder auch
jüngere und gesunde menschen können sehr
schwer und cupid 19 erkranken halt nur
mit einer geringeren häufigkeit mit
stand von heute nachmittag gibt es laut
johns hopkins universität 35 1353
nachgewiesene infizierte in deutschland
3.500 40 menschen haben die infektion
inzwischen überstanden
dr felix zimmermann ist zdf
rechtsexperte und heute unser gast viele
haben hallo für die osterferien urlaub
gebucht nicht alle veranstalter haben
das bis jetzt storniert ist es das
gleiche bekommt man sein geld auf jeden
fall wieder egal ob man selbst storniert
oder eben der reiseveranstalter also
haben wir hier bei pauschalreisen die
möglichkeit jederzeit zurückzutreten von
der reise immer vor reisebeginn das gilt
auch außerhalb von corona zeiten
normalerweise muss man aber eine
entschädigung eine stornierung gebühr
ein reiseveranstalter gezahlt werden
aber hier aufgrund dieser reisewarnung
des auswärtigen amtes liegen
außergewöhnliche umstände vor so heißt
es da im gesetzeswortlaut und dann muss
man keine in cdu zahlen das heißt man
bekommt den reisepreis bei einer
pauschalreise zurück und so ist die
rechtslage aber es gibt viele
reiseveranstalter die das irgendwie
anders behaupten und da muss man dann
offensichtlich ein bisschen unseren
recht kämpfen dann kommt der zimmermann
wir hören uns auch gleich noch mal
wieder die hand in einem seniorenheim in
würzburg gibt es mittlerweile zehn
corona todesfälle 29 heimbewohner sind
infiziert 33 pflegekräfte sind wegen
positiver tests in häuslicher quarantäne
aber wie das virus in die einrichtung
kommen konnte das weiß man noch nicht es
herrscht weiterhin ausnahmezustand in
diesem seniorenheim in würzburg
obwohl seit wochen ein striktes
besuchsverbot und strengste
hygienevorschriften gelten hat das virus
hier eine verheerende spur hinterlassen
wir haben insgesamt mit dem zuletzt
verstorbenen zehn tote zu beklagen
und es waren vielfach hochbetagt oder
alle hochbetagte aber auch entsprechend
multimorbide erkrankte auch bei 33 der
insgesamt 86 mitarbeiter wurde das virus
nachgewiesen sie sind in häuslicher
quarantäne
zusätzliches personal ist nur schwer zu
bekommen
so versuchen die restlichen pflegekräfte
den betrieb so gut es geht aufrecht zu
erhalten nicht einfach denn viele der
heimbewohner sind dement demente gerade
in einrichtungen können sie nicht
fixieren sie können sie auch nicht im
zimmer entsprechend einschließen alle
allein schon aus brandschutzgründen auf
der infektionsstation des uniklinikums
würzburg werden derzeit fünf
heimbewohner behandelt was aber soll mit
den menschen im heim passieren
es wird diskutiert ob er die infizierten
verlegt werden sollen
oder doch jene bei denen das virus
bislang noch nicht nachgewiesen wurde
da haben wir immer noch die gefahr dass
der test negativ ist und die personen
und die nächsten zwei tagen zusätzlich
erkranken
das heißt also wer irgendwo in
anführungszeichen eine saubere
einrichtung die es dann im nachhinein
nicht ist die infektionswelle hat die
pflegeeinrichtung mit voller wucht
erwischt
die große frage aber bleibt wie und
durch wen wurde das virus eingeschleppt
über angehörige auch über personaler
über besucher ob die firmen die im hause
unterwegs gewesen sind wir wissen es
nicht
nun jedenfalls werden alle bewohner und
mitarbeiter der einrichtung getestet in
der hoffnung eine noch größere
ausbreitung des virus in würzburg
verhindern zu können
in den letzten tagen hat man oft dass
das proma virus für jüngere nicht so
gefährlich sei wie für menschen ab 60
dass es allerdings ein irrtum denn immer
mehr junge menschen zeigen inzwischen
auch heftige symptome bei einer corona
infektion
so sieht es aus wenn das corona virus
die lunge befallen
schicht um schicht zeigt die
computertomografie immer mehr weiße
flecken die nicht mehr durchblutet
werden der patient bekommt akuter
atemnot des virus setzt sich in den
zwischenräumen fest und sorgt für dort
für eine entzündung und das bedeutet
wiederum dass der weg des sauerstoffs
von den bläschen in die blutgefäße
drastisch verlängert wird und durch
diese verlängerung des weges haben wir
viel zu wenig sauerstoff aufnahme im
blut es ist die lunge eines über 30
jährigen der vor wenigen tagen erst ins
klinikum stuttgart kam sportlich keine
vorerkrankungen innerhalb von stunden
ein schwer kranker mann
insofern darf sich ein junger gar
keinesfalls in sicherheit wiegen
nun soll dieses beispiel eines des 30
jährigen zeigt er im prinzip aus
heiterem himmel so schwer erkrankt ist
ihm geht es besser doch täglich kommen
neue corona verdachtsfälle auf der
station d4 wird beobachtet welche
symptome die patienten zeigen
gleichzeitig werden elektrolyte
paracetamol und antibiotika gegeben denn
auf das virus setzen sich oft bakterien
bei schwerkranken patienten die noch
nicht intensiv richtig sind viele sie
haben wir die möglichkeit von
überwachungs betten das heißt eine
kontinuierliche aufzeichnung des
blutdrucks der sauerstoffsättigung und
als auf der herzfrequenz wo wir wirklich
sekundengenau sehen ein bisschen
patienten geht und wenn sich so ein
prozent war denn verschlechtern würde
dann wäre die nächste
behandlungsmöglichkeiten der verlegung
möglichkeit der intensivstation
so war es bei diesem über 80 jährigen
innerhalb von 48 stunden ging es um
leben und tod
der großteil ist weiß und es bedeutet
hier ist überall entzündung dieser
patient muss dringend und musste dann
auch nach dieser untersuchung dringend
beachtet werden um das überhaupt
überleben zu können noch haben sie im
klinikum stuttgart die situation im
griff auch personell die fallzahlen aber
nehmen jeden tag deutlich zu husten
fieber abgeschlagenheit jeder der
momentan eines oder mehrere dieser
symptome hat möchte es natürlich wissen
bin ich mit dem corona virus infiziert
aber einen test zu bekommen ist schwer
deswegen bietet zum beispiel ein labor
in hamburg an selbstgemachte abstriche
auszuwerten
eine weitere alternative für diejenigen
die vom arzt zum test geschickt werden
ist ein drive-in lange autoschlangen vor
dem drive-in testzentrum im
saarländischen saarlouis
die menschen die hierher fahren werden
auf das corona virus getestet
der notwendige rachenabstrich wird von
medizinern durchgeführt der vorteil so
einer teststation es können viele
menschen in kurzer zeit getestet werden
allerdings nur die die vom arzt
geschickt wurden inzwischen
krankheitssymptome vorliegen soll
kontakt zu einem positiv getesteten
patienten oder ein aufenthalt in einem
risikogebiet stadt gehabt haben dann ist
eine indikation für einen test gegeben
in diesem medizinischen labor in hamburg
kann man sich auch ohne überweisung ein
teströhrchen abholen den rachenabstrich
selbst machen und das röhrchen in den
briefkasten schmeißen
ich hab das freiwillig gemacht sind
einfach um sicherzugehen dass sich auch
auf arbeit weitermachen kann weil wir
haben oft ganz schwer durchsetzen können
das ist einfach nur aus
sicherheitsgründen weil ich asthmatiker
bin so und deswegen will ich auf nummer
sicher gehen dass mache ich auf eigene
kosten nur für mich selbst mein hausarzt
ist der meinung dass es bei mir nicht
angebracht ist weil ich nicht zu dem
personenkreis gehört der getestet wer
muss nach angaben des labors bekomme
auch hier nicht jeder ein teströhrchen
es müsse eine fragebogen ausgefüllt
werden man halte sich an die richtlinien
des robert koch-instituts dennoch müsse
vielmehr getestet werden
ich möchte ihnen ein beispiel nennen
eine 45 jährige frau die im reinigungs
beruf arbeitet also in vielen firmen
putzt hat angst weil sie so viele
menschen trifft das sie nun infiziert
ist sie weiß es aber nicht es gibt keine
klare exposition sie hat ein bisschen
halsschmerzen kann alles sein und diese
frau versorgt ihre 86-jährige mutter
meine frage darf sie jetzt getestet
werden oder nicht nach meinen augen muss
diese reinigungskraft bevorzugt den test
bekommen
aber das ist nicht erkannt der test
kostet 150 euro
der herzliche leistungen dürfen nur dann
mit der kasse abgerechnet werden wenn
der gesamte vorgang also auch der
abstrich unter ärztlicher aufsicht
stattfindet wichtig sei die
unterscheidung zu einem schnelltest wird
zb über das internet erhältlich ist im
moment entsteht sehr viel unsicherheit
weil alle möglichen anbieter auf dem
markt kommen zum beispiel wird plötzlich
von selbst testen geredet ein selbsttest
machen wir nicht sondern wir machen ein
selbst abstrich methode mit labortests
aber es kursieren eben auch selbst
testen so ähnlich wie
schwangerschaftstest das heißt man nimmt
sich in der praxis oder zu hause den den
abstrich tropft es den abstrich oder
streicht hinaus sind auf ein testträger
oder misst man das selber das machen wir
nicht das es gilt im moment als unseriös
der einzige unterschied zu einem test
beim arzt ist also der dass der patient
den abstrich selbst macht das ergebnis
gibt es erst nach der laboruntersuchung
eine mitarbeiterin zeigt uns wie es geht
sie geht mit dem abstrich tupfer hinter
dem gaumensegel und verschließt den
tupfer dann wieder gut im röhrchen im
moment die ist die oberste priorität
dass ein patient in einer praxis keine
menschen infiziert dh wir müssen den
patienten aus der praxis raushalten aus
den laboren raushalten
in den letzten wochen hat das labor
knapp 5000 abgegebenen proben getestet
eine steile kurve auf dem bildschirm
zeigt deutlich an wenn der test positiv
ist in dem fall wird der patient
benachrichtigt und das gesundheitsamt
informiert ein negativer test allerdings
bedeutet nicht automatisch dass noch
keine infektion stattgefunden hat die
gefahr bei am test es immer dass er mich
in einer falschen sicherheit wiegt wenn
ich als jetzt zum beispiel einen nasen
rachenabstrich mache und ich kann kein
virus nachweisen
ich habe aber auch gar keine symptome
dann heißt das ja nicht dass ich mich
nicht trotzdem am nächsten tag
infizieren kann oder vielleicht sogar
schon infektions bin aber noch in der
informationspanne bin und dass wir es
einfach noch gar nicht im nasen rachen
haben sich vermehrt das heißt
ich kann es noch gar nicht nachweisen
das heißt ein negativer test gibt mir da
manchmal auch eine falsche sicherheit
das interesse der menschen an einem
corona test dürfte mit zunahme der fälle
in den nächsten wochen steigen die
testlabore laufen auf hochtouren
hier in hamburg geht man davon aus dass
es in ganz deutschland schon weit mehr
als 200.000 tests pro woche sein könnten
sagte felix zimmermann ist unser zdf
rechtsexperte und beantwortet jetzt
einige ihrer fragen zum beispiel
schreibt ralf kraft darf mich der
arbeitgeber wochenweise in den
zwangsurlaub schicken
das ist die situation dass wollen jetzt
viele arbeitgeber und das natürlich
total ärgerlich wenn man jetzt gar
keinen urlaub vor hat aber leider ist
die rechtslage für arbeitnehmer so dass
der arbeitgeber das machen darf wenn
betriebliche gründe dafür sprechen
ja und warum wenn ich jetzt sprechen
betriebliche gründe dafür sind der regel
muss man das dann leider in kauf nehmen
diesen zwangsurlaub ok blinder wilhelm
schreibt ich habe 39 überstunden jetzt
soll ich zu hause bleiben und diese
überstunden abbauen
darf man arbeitgeber das verlangen in
die gleiche richtung und die einfach ist
auch die die gleiche das darf er das
darf er verlangen hat sie überstunden
die kann man nicht sich selbst einteilen
wie man lustig ist sondern dann gibt es
dieses direktionsrecht des arbeitgebers
der sagen darf so jetzt wird auch mal
ein guter zeitpunkt jetzt haben wir
gerade nichts zu tun
bitte bommel die jetzt abgeben gut
martin krieg fragt darf man bei einer
fernbeziehung den partner besuchen aber
wieder unglaubliche einschränkungen des
privaten lebens aber zum glück das ist
noch gestattet das sehen auch die
verordnung also die allgemeinverfügung
jetzt die bundesländer verlassen haben
ausdrücklich vor dass lebenspartner noch
besucht werden darf dürfen
das gilt auch dann wenn es eine ausgangs
beschränkung gibt und das gilt auch
bundesländerübergreifend also kann man
kann ruhig durch ganz deutschland also
das erfordert lösen sich heute zu
informieren denn überall geht ja ein
bisschen was anderes aber das habe ich
ja wirklich nachkommt verliert also das
kann man noch überall machen ich hoffe
es bleibt durchweg gut jana gefragt muss
ich die fitness studio beiträge weiter
bezahlen obwohl ich gar keine leistung
in anspruch nehmen kann wenn das
fitnessstudio zu ist
dann ist ja sozusagen die leistung nicht
erbracht worden vom fitnessstudio die da
hilft es im fitnessstudio auch nicht
dass sie sagen kann er wir dürfen ja
nicht eintritt so genannte rechtliche
unmöglichkeit ein ja also die leistung
kann nicht angeboten werden ist
rechtlich unmöglich aber das geht
natürlich dann für denjenigen der dafür
das studio kunde ist dann muss er auch
nicht bezahlen
für diesen für diesen zeitraum in dem
das studio geschlossen dass elfriede
sanktjohanser fragt meine tochter und
ihr lebenspartner die bauen gerade ein
haus wer darf beim bau mithelfen die
baufirma eltern geschwister freunde wer
darf das jetzt haben wir ja dieses diese
kontaktverbot dass sie eigentlich nur
noch zwei leute treffen sollen und dass
nur noch wenn notwendige tätigkeiten
anstehen
eine ausnahme von geld und da muss man
sich natürlich jetzt genau anschauen
weil so ein bau werden da geholfen wird
wenn er eng zusammengearbeitet wird dann
sind mehrere leute plötzlich zusammen
und da gilt eigentlich diese regel wenn
man es genau nimmt was weiterhin erlaubt
ist dass firmen das machen diesen davon
extra ausgenommen aber bei personen
eigentlich nichts also da muss man
aufpassen oder eben die abstandsregel
unbedingt einhalten
danke schön dass man für die einfache
fragen und sie können uns weitere ihre
fragen schicken von denen wir dann
einige hier im studio beantworten die e
mail adresse dafür ist corona kompakte
zdf.de unser corona kompakt finden sie
täglich auch im internet auf youtube und
zwar auf dem kanal der zdf heute den
aktuellsten überblick gibt es auch in
der zdf- heute- app die sie ab jetzt auf
ihr handy laden können sie verpassen
keine entwicklungen und erfahren das
wichtigste auf einen blick
außerdem gibt's da immer wieder auch
live spezialsendungen und interaktive
erklärende stories zu unseren themen
also am besten gleich ausprobieren die
zdf- heute- app ab sofort verfügbar